YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
NOT AN EASY INTERVIEW ON THIS
DAY.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
>> THANK YOU, BRET.
>> Bret: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SAYS THERE
WILL BE NO SECOND SPECIAL
COUNSEL FOR NOW.
JEFF SESSIONS IS REJECTING A
REPUBLICAN REQUEST FOR A SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR TO LOOK INTO ALLEGED
BIAS AT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
AND THE F.B.I.
BUT HE IS AUTHORIZING AN
INVESTIGATION AND LEAVING THE
DOOR OPEN FOR MORE POSSIBLE
ACTION LATER.
CHIEF NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT ED
HENRY IS HERE WITH THE BREAKING
DETAILS.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
THIS COULD BE A BIG DEAL BECAUSE
WHAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
REALLY SAYING IS HE MAY NOT NEED
HIS SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL JUST
YET TO FIND OUT WHETHER F.B.I.
AND JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS
DURING THE OBAMA YEARS BROKE
LAWS WHEN THEY ENGAGED IN ABUSE
TO SPY ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
BECAUSE HE ALREADY HAS A
CRIMINAL PROSECUTOR ALL OVER IT.
SESSIONS REVEALING FOR THE FIRST
TIME HE ALREADY HAS BEEN QUIETLY
HAVING U.S. ATTORNEY JOHN HUBER
OF UTAH OPERATING, OF COURSE,
OUTSIDE OF THE BELTWAY, USING
HIS PROSECUTORIAL POWERS WITH A
BROAD MANDATE TO INVESTIGATE
MISCONDUCT THAT COULD EXTEND
BEYOND FISA ABUSE.
JAMES COMEY AND ANDREW McCABE
COULD BE FACING SCRUTINY FOR NOT
ONLY FAILING TO TELL THEM THAT
THE DOSSIER WAS PAID FOR IN THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN, HE COULD BE
LOOKING AT McCABE'S LEAKING AND
LYING TO INVESTIGATORS AND THOSE
F.B.I. TEXT MESSAGES.
SESSIONS WRITING "I AM CONFIDENT
HIS REVIEW WILL INCLUDE A FULL,
COMPLETE AND OBJECTIVE
EVALUATION OF THESE MATTERS IN A
MANNER THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE LAW AND THE FACTS.
I RECEIVE REGULAR UPDATES FROM
HIM AND UPON THE CONCLUSIONS OF
HIS REVIEW WILL RECEIVE HIS
RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO WHETHER
ANY MATTERS, NOT CURRENTLY UNDER
INVESTIGATION, SHOULD BE OPENED.
WHETHER ANY MATTERS CURRENTLY
UNDER INVESTIGATION REQUIRE
FURTHER RESOURCES OR WHETHER ANY
MATTERS MERIT THE APPOINTMENT OF
A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
NOW, SESSIONS FACED HEAT AGAIN
LAST NIGHT WHEN IT WAS REVEALED
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT INSPECTOR
GENERAL WAS REVIEWING THIS AND
CRITICS SAID THAT THAT OFFICIAL
THERE DOES NOT HAVE
PROSECUTORIAL POWERS.
WELL, JOHN HUBER DOES.
AND REMEMBER, SESSIONS HINTED AT
THIS WITHOUT NAMING HUBER IN A
RECENT INTERVIEW.
WATCH.
>> I HAVE APPOINTED A PERSON
OUTSIDE OF WASHINGTON MANY YEARS
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
LOOK AT ALL THE ALLEGATIONS THAT
THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SENT TO US AND WE'RE
CONDUCTING THAT INVESTIGATION.
>> HUBER WAS FIRST NOMINATED BY
BARACK OBAMA.
IF HE BRINGS CRIMINAL CHARGES,
IT WILL HAVE CREDIBILITY.
IT WILL BE NOTED THIS IS SOMEONE
WHO IS RENOMINATED BY PRESIDENT
TRUMP WITH THE BACKING, WE
SHOULD NOTE OF CONSERVATIVE